hi good morning everybody thank you for
coming today today I'm gonna be talking
about functional web programming in net
with the safe stack and first question
that you're likely to have is Who am I
my name is Anthony uh you can follow me
on Twitter brynbrown 93 where I
occasionally tweet about code there's my
work email address and sitcom position
ID comm you've got any questions after
day then feel free to drop me an email
day today I work as an f-sharp
consultant helping deliver things like
websites completely written in F sharp
and that's what I'm gonna be talking
about today really is about how we can
actually deliver fully functional
websites which use F sharp along the
entire stack now first thing to point
out is that it's actually quite easy to
do functional programming in dotnet
because if your ring on the.net
framework or doughnut core or anything
like that you've got access to a
fantastic functional programming
language in F sharp so first of all what
is f sharp well as I've just said it's a
functional programming language the
syntax is significantly different to a
lot of what people are commonly used to
I it says ml based syntax so it's closer
to things like Haskell and oh camel than
it is to c-sharp or Java as I mentioned
it runs on dotnet and dotnet core but
it's far from a new language in fact
it's been in development since the early
2000s it was really around 2010 the F
sharp came into prominence though I it
was shipped as part of Visual Studio
2010 at that time Microsoft gave a
justification for the development of as
sharp as it's a fantastic language for
things like maths and Finance which it
is but over the years it's meant that F
sharp has had this kind of stigma
attached to it that you can only ever
use F sharp for mass and Finance and so
whenever I get asked this question which
happens quite frequently the answer is
an emphatic no right there's a fantastic
thriving ecosystem around the f-sharp
language and it's developed into
something much more and because it's you
know a general-purpose language that
runs on dotnet it means you've got
access to this fantastic ecosystem of
things like libraries for web
development for mobile app development
for you know for all the finance
applications that you might need to
develop or for everything else that you
need to develop as well in fact at work
I use it every day for developing
everything from console applications to
cloud services to web applications F
sharp is usable absolutely everywhere
and in fact the techniques that we use
within functional programming actually
make complex tasks really really simple
and a lot easier to understand and so
today I'm gonna be talking about how we
can take all of these benefits of our
shop and apply them to the things that
we have to do on a more day-to-day basis
you know it's not not all of us are
trying to cure cancer or and send
rockets to Mars for a lot of us it's
just a case of we need to develop a web
application which users can log in to
tick a few checkboxes that gets updated
in a database and f-sharp is a fantastic
fit for that the way we typically do
this in F sharp is using this thing
called the safe stack so what is safe
well on the safe website it says safe is
an end-to-end functional first stack for
cloud ready web development that
emphasizes type safe program which is a
lot of words to say it's a set of
libraries that lets you develop
everything you need to run a web site in
F sharp
so safe is made up of four core elements
there's a server-side web application
framework there's a hosting environment
and platform services there's a
client-side web application framework
and there's a UI framework now these
four core elements of safe came together
because ourselves at composition IT and
a whole bunch of other people within the
f-chart community sat down and said
right how are we all developing web
applications in F sharp if we've got
something we've got some common ground
between us then it make sense to
standardize on a core set of tools and
libraries to make a fantastic experience
for everybody else and so these were the
four things that were common across all
more specifically for each of those
these things as part of the safe stack
we've got for our web application
framework Saturn and giraffe for our
cloud hosting we've got either Azure or
AWS for a client-side library we've got
fable and then for a UI framework we've
got L mesh these were the four
components that we found to be most in
line with what others in the f-sharp
community were using so we looked at
these four things and if you look at it
closely you'll notice that if you look
at the first letter they form a really
nice acronym so we thought this is
something that we absolutely have to run
with the great thing about safe is
everything is dotnet core compatible so
there's no need to have don't net
framework there's no need to have mono
installed anything like that it also
means that it runs on Windows Mac and
Linux so if you're not a.net developer
and coming up and F sharp from the
perspective of an ojs to have working in
Java Square
to Ruby on Rails developer then you'll
be used to like the cross-platform
nature of these tools f-sharp fantastic
in that regard
donate core runs great across all three
platforms and we're not tied in to any
one particular editor either you can use
Visual Studio 2019 vs code JetBrains
Rider all these kinds of tools we've
aimed to support as part of the SAF
stack so I mentioned that these were the
four components that we came up with as
we were looking into safe but why did we
actually come up with them well for a
lot of people coming into a shop a lot
of what they see is brand new you know
they might have experience doing c-sharp
or Java or JavaScript we've got a very
in the world cases a very low approach
to solving problems you know you'll have
something like a an API controller that
you have to inherit from and override
methods on those kind of things so we
wanted to be able to share our
experiences across a whole stack of how
you can solve these problems better in F
sharp
I mentioned that we'd seen this clear
overlap in how lots of other like
sub-communities within the F sharp world
were solving problems and so we noticed
a lot of opportunity for collaboration
across all of us so we're not you know
wasting our time and creating lots of
duplicate content out there that makes
it confusing for beginners to get
started and obviously as I mentioned it
makes a really nice acronym safe works
well so let's now move on to looking at
the components individually let's start
with our back-end web services our s in
this case saturn now saturn doesn't
exist in a vacuum
Saturn is actually part of the asp.net
ecosystem and Saturn sits at the very
top layer of our web application stack
Saturn is of nice library for a lot of
idiomatic f-sharp configuration or
of dotnet core or asp.net web
applications but it also provides a lot
of new and interesting approaches to
developing api s-- as well which we'll
see later on Saturn itself though sits
on top of this library called giraffe if
you've had any exposure to F shop you
might have heard of giraffe it's a
library that provides functional style
Combinator's to allow you to develop web
applications in a more functional style
so rather than relying on classes we're
instead relying on functions underneath
giraffe is asp.net core I'm sure you're
all aware or at least have heard of
asp.net core you know it's the hip new
thing in Microsoft and what Microsoft
have pretty much devoted their time
going forwards towards and at the bottom
of the stack there we've got Kestrel so
there's a great thing about Saturn is
that whilst we've got all this F shop
specific tooling and library what we've
actually got is the ability to use all
this underlying asp.net core ecosystem
so it's no longer a case of having to
reinvent the wheel if you're doing
something in F sharp what you're able to
do instead is if Microsoft come out and
decide they're going to rewrite that
popular open source library that
everybody else is using and force you to
use it great you can just use their
implementation now rather than having to
rewrite their own implementation or you
know if you need to use something that
you really don't want to have to
implement yourself for example Active
Directory Integration
that's all supported thanks to the
asp.net core active directory levels but
a big draw of Saturn is it provides some
really nice abstractions for doing
things that shop that would look a bit
awkward at times if you were writing
them in F sharp so Saturn provides
abstractions for things like your
overall application configuration
it provides configuration for things
like how you actually direct all your
incoming web requests to all your
different routes we also has these
abstractions to enable us to build
better pipelines so as a request comes
in how should we modify that request how
should we modify the response that gets
sent back should we actually just drop
the request entirely and finally we've
got this nice controller abstraction
which provides us with an alternative
way of creating crud style api's yeah so
if you're just doing things that need
create read update delete Saturn's got
abstractions that make it a little bit
more idiomatic and a little bit easier
let's start with configuration I'm sure
if you've used asp.net core then you've
had to set up your asp.net core app and
you've got this big chain of dot use
blah news blah blah you can do that in F
shop if you want to but Saturn uses a
different approach so under the hood
it's still using all of those libraries
it's still using all of those calls but
in F sharp method chaining isn't as
common it's not like the idiomatic way
of doing things so Saturn provides these
computation expressions and we'll see an
example of one in just a second it's an
entirely strongly typed configuration
alright so it looks there's no types
defined anywhere or anything like that
from what you see but under the hood
everything is strongly typed so you
can't be accidentally passing in the
wrong thing anyway here is a very simple
application and we've got this
application computation expression you
can see along the top there we've got
all that app equal application curly
bracket and then we've got each of these
small decorative statements so we want
to say we've got a gyro which
is listening on zero zero zero zero and
a random port we're going to use it a
Rooter as part of our application and we
specify our Rooter elsewhere we say we
want a memory cache as part of our
application we want to serve static
content from a public path we want to
configure our serialization using that
service config that we've got there and
we want to use gzip and then we call run
app at the bottom so if you've used
asp.net core in the past a lot of the
things that you're seeing here you might
be able to see how they map on to the
actual underlying asp.net core method
calls next up our Reuters so Reuters are
housed at and links and incoming web
requests path to a function that you've
got running on your server one of the
really interesting things is the fact
that Reuters are all strongly typed even
in the URL parameters sounds a bit
strange but you'll see what I mean in
just a second and the great thing about
Reuters is they follow one of the key
principles of functional programming
which is everything should be composable
right you should be able to say I've got
a Rooter I want to join another route up
to that and another Rooter up to that
and another Rooter up to that so you can
create small focused components with
your application and then link them
together in stages so here's an example
of a Rooter now because this is our shop
we're going to read bottom to top rather
than top to bottom so at the bottom here
I've got this Rooter this Rooter here is
going to be saying whenever I receive a
request I'm going to check my url and
I'm going to divert it where it's needed
so let's start with this get at the
bottom we say if we get some things
that's on the path /foo we're going to
pass through into the get food mess
but if we receive something which is on
the path slash API slash office what
we're actually going to do is we're
going to forward all of our requests
into our child Rita so you can start to
see how this might enable you to compose
your application a little bit
differently yeah so you can focus on
like per application components so you
can have a file for all of your office
API a file for all of your people API so
you can focus on a specific problem area
in a specific part of your application
and in this ritter at the top we say if
we've just got get slash then we just
returned all of our offices but we've
got this get F / % s here so if any of
you have done any C long long ago
you might remember calling things like
printf in C where you specify a format
string and the C compiler will format
all of your string out for you F sharp
also uses printf and it uses you know %
s % D these kind of identifiers except
what f-sharp does is the compiler is
smart enough to know that that % s means
that you need it you need a string in
there and so this get office by ID
function if that's not got a string as a
parameter it'll fail to compile so if
you expect your body to be an integer
and you pass get office bio D which has
got an integer parameter your
application will fail to compile at this
point and so you then either got to fix
your get office by ID function to take
in a string instead of an integer or
you've got to fix your URL path to take
in an integer or taking into it rather
than a straight
sometimes though we want a bit more of a
higher level on top of just functions
right we want an abstraction for dealing
with more objects so if you kind of
think as Reuters as path to functions
controllers are more like paths to
objects and they provide these
abstractions for doing all of your
credit up operations so if you want to
do create read update delete controllers
a great fit for that and another great
thing about them is they're completely
composable
with anything else that takes in a URL
so if you've got a Rooter then you can
have a controller as a child of a Rooter
you can have a controller as a child of
a controller you can use all of these
kind of composition ideas that make
functional programming a really
attractive solution let's take a look at
controller now once again F shop so
reading bottom to top what we've got is
an example of an API where we might have
say a meeting room booking service right
so we've got a meeting a meeting takes
place in an office so we've got an API
that provides all of our offices an API
that provides all of our meetings at the
bottom here we've got our controller
that handles our offices and so we use
this computation expression again
similar to how we did when we used
application similar to how we did when
we used Ritter we have this index here
index takes in a function which is just
going to allow us to list out everything
so we don't have any URL parameters in
this case we just want the overall list
of what's available at that resource if
we want a specific thing though then we
can implement show so in that case we
get an ID and we can view specific ID
and under the hood what Saturn is going
to do is it's going to work on is ematic
REST API concepts and so if you've got
this office controller running a slash
office your index
is gonna be get slash office your show
is going to be get slash office slash ID
you've also got the ability to do delete
update all sorts in there and all of
those are going to be mapped under the
hood into the appropriate HTTP verbs but
one thing that I said is we can have
composable controllers so we've got our
sub controller word here and that says
I've got a meetings controller which is
going to be a child of my current office
controller and what that's going to do
is you'll notice that it takes in a
parameter at the top there
Saturn knows that if you've got
something like slash office /id
slash meetings you're gonna need that
office ID to be able to list out all of
your meetings related to it and so it
provides it in there and you can then do
the exact same thing so indexes you can
do your show your update your delete
another concept is pipelines so we can
create these composable pipelines in
Saturn and these are things that operate
on the request and the response and it
provides multiple operations that we're
likely to want to do so for every
request that comes into our Web API we
can choose to either modify the incoming
request so we could choose to add an
extra header if we needed to we could
modify the outgoing response so it could
change the serialization technology that
we're using or we could just drop the
request in tightly so in that case you
know somebody's failed to supply their
authentication information and so here's
an example of a pipeline once again
you'll notice computation expression as
a way of actually building the thing up
these things are entirely composable as
well using this plug words there so we
can plug in an extra pipeline and feed a
pipeline through a pipeline and then
it's just a case of things like set
header or requires authentication all
these kind of things
are things that are going to happen at
every stage for every request that comes
in and so we can create as many
pipelines as we want we can compose them
all together and we can be selective
where we apply them if we only want to
apply them to one of our controllers
find will only apply it to that
controller if you want to apply it to
all of them we can do that as well
Saturn itself is built on top of giraffe
which is on top of asp.net core which
allows us to use all that asp.net
middleware that's already been written
and the people are continuing to develop
and another great thing is we can run
Saturn wherever we can host asp.net core
so we can host it on kestrel we can host
it in places like as your functions you
can even host it in AWS London as well
it's a case of you're already able to
use this entire ecosystem of
technologies that are already available
to us that's the backend how about the
front-end so well and good being able to
develop our web services an F shop but
are we able to bring concepts like
strong static typing to the front end
where JavaScript reigned supreme
well yeah we can with this tool called
fable which is an F sharp to JavaScript
compiler which takes your f sharp and
compiles it into readable modern
JavaScript which runs in any web browser
so that's for me one of the Mait one of
the important things as well the
readable modern JavaScript it's not a
case of at all generating just kind of
cobbled together JavaScript under the
hood this is using technologies like
Babel to generate standards-compliant
JavaScript which is understandable and
debuggable
but because we're running f-sharp on the
front end and f-sharp on the back end
one of the great things that were able
to do is share code so if we've got
things like
types and functions we can take out net
core API you know that we've written in
giraffe or Saturn and bring our
client-side JavaScript as well so the
stuff that we've written in Fable elvish
and share it across the two so if you've
got stuff like validation logic just use
it across both your front end and your
back end if you've got your API model
share it across both rather than
rewriting it twice in two very different
languages one of the interesting things
about fable though is it actually is
designed to be a part of the JavaScript
ecosystem so it's not designed to burn
everything to the ground and start from
scratch what you're able to do is reuse
all of the existing JavaScript tooling
that you know so it integrates with
things like web pack if you're used to
the redux and react dev tools then these
are the exact kind of things you'll be
using if you're creating fable
applications and another great thing is
it allows you to use all those existing
JavaScript libraries so fable itself is
distributed through NPM the actual
compiler and everything so you can
consume any other wipers that are on NPM
as well so if you need to use left pads
then feel free to go and use left pad
but it's not enough that we can just
write our F sharp on the front end
because well we've got a short code and
we know what good F sharp code looks
like so let's try and write good F sharp
code everywhere good f sharp code for me
is immutable it's readable it makes
sense you can see it and you can reason
about what's going to happen and for me
a lot of UI programming is done wrong
for me mutability in your UI is a
significant liability that leads to
weird bugs and race conditions that you
don't know what to do about and our nyan
impossible to debug there's this
complexity involved with handling
asynchronous operations you know you've
got a UI you click a button you go off
to a web server your web server comes
back in the meantime you're you I might
have completely changed how do you cope
with that
you know what do you do there's also
this lack of composability of components
so if you've got this one page that
you've done fantastically in mvvm there
was this promise that you'd be able to
just take this page and move it anywhere
and that's great in theory but in
practice it's never quite worked out
like that you always ended up having a
bit of application specific logic
somewhere to make it work and that makes
it difficult to take one page that
you've written somewhere and put it
somewhere completely different and then
we've got all this difficulty of doing
stuff on the main threads like why
should I have to care what thread my
application is currently running on and
whether I can do stuff to the UI or not
so instead of doing all this let's talk
about functional programming concepts
and how we can apply those to the UI so
in functional programming you might have
been exposed to things like folds or
reduce or if you've been using link you
might have used things like aggregate in
this case we start off with an initial
state yeah we have this initial state
that describes our application on
startup we can then render that state to
our UI so we can just paint the picture
of our UI of what it is for that current
state then every time something on the
UI happens we're going to dispatch a
command that command is going to be
picked up by an update function and that
update function is going to generate a
completely new state then once we've got
that new state we just render the whole
thing out again
all right so to show it in a diagram if
we start in the middle we've got our
model we're gonna render out our model
into a view and that's going to be sent
to our web browser whenever we do
something like interact with that page
or interact with the web browser we're
going to fire off an event that event
gets mapped into a command that command
then gets passed into our update
function which takes in the model at the
point in time it received the update
command from there we can look at the
current state and we can look at the
things that wants to change the current
state and work out is it something that
is valid for a change or is it something
that we should just ignore or do
something like raise an error about and
we can just keep repeating this and
repeating this and repeating this
forever and ever and ever
let's see how we do it in F sharp so
what I've got here is a very simple
model to demonstrate a counter I've got
this counter model at the top which has
just got an integer for the counter
value and then I've got a set of
commands that we might commonly use so
we've got the ability to increment to
decrement and to reset automatically you
can see straight away exactly what it is
the my application is going to be doing
right this is the entirety of the state
within my application how do I then
render my state out yeah what does that
counter value look like well we can just
describe it with HTML you know we've got
a div and because we've been passed in
our model we can just use our model as
part of our view so in this case we've
got a haitch one tag so for a heading
and then we've got the button and we've
got another div down here with our
counter value and another thing we've
been passed in is this dispatch value so
dispatch is a function that allows us to
do
batch commands into our update logic and
so whenever we click the plus button
we're going to dispatch an increment
command whenever we click the minus
button we're going to dispatch a
decrement command that's all there is to
it when it comes to the update we have
an initial value which is the starting
value of our application in the case
where you've got a brand new webpage
open it makes sense that you're going to
have a counter that is initialized to 0
it might also make sense that you have a
counter it's initialized to 100 but it's
obvious what your initial status we've
then got our update our update is going
to take in a command which we dispatched
from our UI on our last slide and the
existing model so what came out of the
last update or if there was no last
update what was the initial State
and then what we can do is we can
pattern match across it and we can say
was it an increment great then our state
should be States +1 was their decrement
then it should be state minus 1
was it a reset in that case reset it
back to the initial state because this
is a shop because this is discriminated
unions if we missed out one of these
cases the compiler is going to complain
at us and say why haven't you considered
the case where you've got a reset event
come in from the UI it forces us to
think about cases which we might not
have ordinarily considered because they
weren't immediately obvious and then
it's just a case of joining the
components together so we say I'm going
to create a simple application here's my
initial state here's my update function
here's my view join them all together
build it as part of a react application
and mount it on this HTML element and
just run the whole program and I'm gonna
let Elvish deal with all let elvish deal
with the whole concept of
multi-threading yeah let L miss deal
with updating the UI with
under the hood use react so you get
great performance because you're not
just re-rendering the whole UI fantastic
thing is whilst this talk is about web
development elvish isn't just for the
web using elvish you can write things
like console applications you can write
WPF apps you can write it's a marine
forms apps and you can write fable apps
as we've seen here that's fantastic
you've now got your full application
it's all written and it's running great
on your local machine for a lot of
people though they want to actually
deploy it so that people can see it
somewhere within safe we've got quite a
few different options and we've got
things like as your we've got darker
we've got kubernetes we've got Google
Cloud all sorts the ones that we tend to
focus on though are Azure and dabka I'm
just going to talk briefly about the as
your side now so as part of the safe
template we've got one click deploy but
we've done it right right so we've got
the whole command-line tooling built for
you and so we just generate a build
script that you can consume as part of
your CI process or as part of your local
development process so you get the
ability to do build deploy locally and
it'll deploy but you can take that drop
it onto your belt server and run
one-click deploy there as well we also
provide things like repeatable
deployments with as your resource
manager so we know what components are
required to get a safe application
working and so we've supplied an arm
template with things like the as your
app service that will be needed
we've also provisioned and azure sequel
database and as your storage in there
because these are the common sorts of
things that people are going to need
when they're developing their
applications to run on Azure and as I
said we can deploy from CLI from the
fake
scripts from the build server for anyway
because we've got one click deploy
that's done right we've also provided
really deep integration with Azure
platform services so we've got things
like Ana's your type and Azure storage
type for writer so you can point your f
sharp compiler at your as your storage
instance and the F sharp compiler will
look across your Azure storage and say
oK you've got a container which has got
this folder which we've got this folder
and this folder and this folder and it
will generate these as statically
provided parameters that you can use at
compile time so you get type checking of
data that is stored in your Azure
storage account we've also got things
like automatic app insights integration
so you can publish events from Saturn
because it uses dotnet core so into the
hood it's using the asp.net core app
insights interation there's also work
being done to publish events from fable
so you know somebody clicks on a button
in your UI you publish that event to app
insights so you can use it later on
that's not all though that's the library
site but there's more to development
than just gluing libraries together you
need to make sure that it's an actual
enjoyable experience for people who are
using those libraries and we've invested
quite heavily into that safe adds
terminology for sharing experiences
right so it's a case of if you need to
add authentication for a safe app you're
not gonna have to go to a whole bunch of
different places and try and glue
together little snippets of code which
work in one example but not necessarily
in another we've also invested in things
like automated touring for creating safe
apps so we've got a dotnet core template
which I'll be showing later on there's
also better end-to-end documentation as
I say this links quite heavily with the
concept of sharing experiences the
terminology required for that because
you can write a blog post on here's how
I did authentication in safe and people
know that that means Saturn fable elvish
and possibly some deployment to Azure as
well and it also means that we can
provide better end-to-end towing so
we're able to really embrace new
concepts in development with things like
hot reloading of your application and
not having to rely on f5 debug
constantly it also means that we can
provide more in-depth training and
samples you know we're not just limited
to here's a Web API that I wrote in
Saturn and here's a small front-end for
a faith back-end I wrote were able to
develop more bit more larger
applications which provide best
practices on how you go about developing
applications in F sharp so let me just
talk briefly about the safe dev process
this is one of the things that I
mentioned as you know we want to have
better end-to-end tooling and typically
you can have a process that looks
something like the following so you
change your code you compile it you
start your application you hit f5 you
wait for it to hit breakpoint you find
out what's gone wrong okay right that
was that was silly of me why did I do
that
let me change it you change it you wait
for it to compile you start your
application again you debug and then you
realize that you actually made a mistake
in the change as well and so you can
have this really long feedback cycle of
waiting you know few minutes between
making a small change and having your
application ready to be debugged again
safe we've focused on this concept of
just hot reloading your application
constantly so whenever you save we're
going to recompile and there's part of
that recompile we're just going to make
that new version of your application
wife constantly so what you're then able
to do is
just hack away at some code foot back to
web browser and see everything's updated
for a lot of people as well commercial
support was a deal-breaker you know a
lot of the eff short world is just
open-source applications and open source
libraries and this for a lot of people
was a bit alarming because they didn't
know who to turn to if they need support
so the safe brand now enables all the
consultants who's out there
to focus on what it is that they can
help people with in the eff short world
and it's now reducing the risk of
adoption of F shop for a lot of
organizations out there consistent
documentation is another one we've got
the safe brand and it allows for
end-to-end coverage of functionality
which affects the whole stack you know
previously if you just got Saturn it was
one thing to have an API it was one
thing to have an API with authentication
it was then something completely
different to integrate that
authentication with your JavaScript
front-end or your mobile app or whatever
it might be so safe really does allow
developers to get up to speed on the
full stack features very quickly and
we've got a complete documentation site
that's available there at safe stack
github io / Doc's right you've all
listened to me talk for quite a while
now so let's go onto the code side of
things code wise we've got the safe
template so as part of that we've got a
dotnet core template which enables you
to configure your application exactly as
you want it we've got options on the
server if do you want Saturn or do you
just want draft the layer below Saturn
do you want layout you know do you want
CSS files included do you want to use
something like former which is I don't
know if any of you've ever used the CSS
library Bulmer similar to bootstrap but
former is an F sharp library that
provides
typesafe components built on top of
Bulma we've got things like remoting
which is kind of like ER RPC style
framework for f-sharp across JavaScript
clients and f-sharp backends deployment
you've got things like no deployment you
know I I'm gonna handle that myself
we've got things like docker or as your
as well JavaScript dependencies if you
want to use NPM use NPM if you want to
use yond use yan we've then got fake
scripts our build scripts so fake is an
f-sharp belt tool similar to like cake
in c-sharp and this enables you have
enables you to handle over your build
and run all your deployment we also
provide things like custom docker files
for bundling up all your application so
that it can be created as a docker
container let's take a look at the safe
template so I've got a new safe template
I've created here and we provide really
nice integration with vs code so if
you've not got anything installed
related to F sharp what we do is we
provide all the recommendations that you
need to get started quickly with
developing a sharp applications in vs
code so you'd need things like the C
shop extension because that's how they
donate core debugger a ship to invest
code you want things like ionize a shop
for all of your f sharp intellisense
support and then when we've got our
application we've got our client sites
with everything that's needed scaffold
out a new elvish application running in
the browser and we've got our
server-side application which has got
everything we need in it to be running
our Saturn API and we also provide all
the build scripts so it's just a case of
doing fake build run
and then I can leave that be whilst I
show off some of the code here you know
we've got our Saturn API we provide
examples of how you know to use a Saturn
API if we go into our client site we've
got a full elvish app that gets
scaffolded you can then modify to your
usage in terms of additional - link
we've got our web pack config all
supplied out of the box so you don't
have to mess around trying to spend six
hours setting up your project you can
dive straight into coding we've got all
of the arm templates if you're doing
this with Azure
so you can deploy instantly to Azure
and then as my application is running I
can see it running in my web browser and
so I can click the button and update the
state it's going to pull down the state
from my API that I've got there
initially I've got all this integration
with the existing JavaScript tool chain
yeah I can go and see that using the
Redux dev tools I've had this increment
command go through five times if I click
it again I can see it go through there I
get full time travel debugging as well
so I've just moved back to this command
and if I come here you can see that my
state has transitioned to what it was at
the point of that command so it provides
different opportunities for debugging
very simple applications like that are
fantastic is a template to get your from
running but it can be difficult
understanding how to structure much
larger broader applications which cover
multiple different areas and so if part
as part of that we've provided example
applications we've got a safe dojo this
is more of a fill-in-the-blanks exercise
so what it'll do is they'll give you a
starter application and it walks you
through here's what you need to change
to add this feature this feature
demonstrates how Elvish works how Saturn
api's works there's also the safe
bookstore this is a pretty large
application which includes things like
storage deployment with docker
authentication is in there as well and
we've got an example put together which
is the safe search this is another
larger application and includes
integration with things like Azure as
well so how do you use as your search
how do you use as your storage so safe
search is all available up on github you
can pull this down deploy it as you want
there is also a demo website up where
you can search for a location in the UK
and it'll pull down properties relating
to your search location and under the
hood we're using all these services like
as your search like is your storage and
so you can see how you can use all these
with a shop so we've got this entire
application here which you can dive into
and see best practices for doing
idiomatic web applications in F sharp
next up we've got the safe dojo so the
safe dojo is
an introductory application to help you
get started developing web applications
in a shop so this is a workshop that
I've done with a few user groups now as
well and we provide you with this nearly
complete web application was just a few
missing pieces you can pick this up and
you can follow the instructions file and
it's going to guide you through how to
add things like adding a new end point
to your API it'll cover adding shared
code that you can consume across your
front-end in your back-end you can add a
map using Bing Maps you can implement
weather API which goes to an external
endpoint and I've had great success in
this with people who have got a lot of
experience with F sharp but not might
not have looked at the web side of
things but it's also equally
approachable by people who have no a
sharp web experience and I've seen
groups of people who have not touched
fgo up before managed to go through this
in an hour and a half to two hours
and that's all available on github as
part of under the compositional IT
organization if you're interested in
learning more about save stack then I
recommend following the save stack
Twitter account at safe underscore stack
or watching the github organization at
github comm slash safe stack or visiting
the safe stack website at save stack
github dot if you've got any questions
we have a few questions now if there's
anything that you get think of when you
get back to your office next week and
you think I will shout out hits that
don't be afraid of dropping me an email
and I'll try and direct you it's the
right resources thank you for that is
anybody got any questions yeah I've got
a question here
yeah
so question is is there anything like
swagger integration available for things
like Saturn
it is currently actively being worked on
its hopes that they'll be included as
part of the giraffe library I don't know
there's been a lot of work involved in
doing that but as far as I'm aware
currently it's been delayed as part of
the Microsoft endpoint based routing
it's going to provide a different
approach to doing it and so I think the
decisions have been made to postpone it
a little while otherwise it's gonna be a
case of doing one thing and then having
to reinvent the wheel a few months later
when dotnet or asp.net core 3 comes out
I think any of the questions
no questions
so suave we originally wanted to make
safe you know quite an open concept and
so we originally did say you could use
suave or satin or giraffe but we found
it quite limiting because suave you know
it's its own dedicated thing Saturn
runs on asp.net core we found ourselves
using Saturn a lot more and reaching out
to it a lot more just because we've got
that whole asp.net core ecosystem
available under the hood it made it
difficult for us to recommend suave as
an option because you can end up
reinventing the wheel for a lot of use
cases and so we just ultimately decided
as the template started to grow and we
added more features to it that suave we
can't really recommend and maintain
going forwards any other questions I own
where's that it's five minutes until
lunch so I don't want that to sway your
decision of whether you want to ask
question it's not
we're friends with as you're an AWS but
what about Google Cloud yes we do
support Google cloud so as part of the
safe template one of the options that's
available if I come to the safe state
website and go into FAQ components safe
template deployment options there it is
we do have a pretty broad range of
deployment options now we tend to focus
on as you're an AWS because that's what
the core maintain is and mostly
comfortable with docker as well actually
but there is support there for deploying
to Google Cloud App Engine or Google
Cloud kubernetes engine or Heroku or iOS
so these are all options available if
you do want to use something a bit
different to Azure or AWS any other
questions going going gone
[Applause]